che magia è ma buongiorno amici
incredibili oggi farò una magica e
scompaio attenzione e riprendimi proprio
chiederà grandangolare 3 2 1 che magia
incredibile in realtà sono qui è per
questo che siete iscritti al mio canale
di youtube amici miei
buongiorno ragazzi oggi sono in un'altra
puntata un'altra nuova puntata mi piace
oggi ci ritroviamo qui perché rispetto
ad altre puntate oggi
alziamo l'asticella vedete questa
qualche è una coperta
come ho detto prima la mettiamo un passo
le gambe perché ho freddo e direi che
per le scatolare ci serve ovviamente cm
direi di far apparire bacco il freddo
carino oggi visto che è una puntata
veramente diversa dal solito validi
perché non sono qua dentro però so chi è
il nostro speciale e signore e signori
se tra i cebi altro et voilà non so cosa
l ospite speciale
mamma mia come venuta bene come è venuta
bene se volete lo svelo il boccone
prossimo video ve lo spieghiamo
possibile 100 mila mi piace a sul razzi
ragazzi grazie
oggi abbiamo già nobile e siccome io
deduco che contenuto del pacco facciamo
sparire si aspetta il padre andava bene
allora che imbarca mozziconi genio i
signori viso intossicati di scatto forse
sa che la ci vuole perché no io si sente
come se io dentro casa che ho fatto in
ribasso allora non le scatole scatola
adescato la copa come scatola mi rimanda
ma io non sono molto esperto di cose di
magia quindi sicuramente se non ci sarà
un pollo allora va dentro no però
allora vi facciamo vedere cosa c'è
all'interno del pacco che ora va bene tu
sei vestito vederlo
no esatto va bene ma cronache com'è
possibile che cosa più semplice di tutte
ti faccio un gioco ti faccio scegliere
una carta
prendi una riguardi la ricordi da per
vederti tuoi amici fanno vedere a tutti
i tuoi amici c questa la carta io non
sono tuo amico l'attesa damasco la
mescola poker e mescola hai vinto niente
perfetta perché io credo che la tua
carta sia il 10 di picche non era una
cosa e questo iniziamo con questo ti
ricordi la casi signore al 10 come prima
cosa dovrei imparare questo se questa è
la prima cosa che facciamo qualcosa è
bellissimo però è fantastico lo voglio
che ti fai per aprirla di un colpetto
personaggio è bellissimo per chiuderlo
metti le mani così e fai questo ma dai
mai fatta in fila c'e la mano dentro e
fatti lasciano aprire e fate lo score
del suo e giuseppe di braccio e belli di
streghe rayman tasti come le chiama non
lo so allora preferisco complicato o una
skill da imparare
preferisco rompicapo ma questa è una
scatola non era un pick up con molti di
jack che sono quelli che tu devi
riuscire a capire cioè come 4 feltrini 4
feltrinelli no che sensazione che culo
ragazzi ragazzi e facciamo carta nuova
per sto male e casa di scelto 9 ci credi
9 riquadri la donna di quadri ma com'è
possibile questa cosa è possibile
no non è possibile no siete per milo
esagerato non ci credo ma in culo
esagerata come hai fatto a metterlo la
demo che ma tu hai il culo e capisci che
il culo esagera perché ciò che solo
pronto pronto ecco la sorprende adesso
prenderla soprattutto cos'è questa cosa
in questo caso facciamo la mandiamo
avanti con il prossimo ieri in questo
senso è molto importante
rando cacao e lascia lo fai tu adesso
locatore non ho avuto io non sono capaci
a fare queste cose ma io mi brucia
regolo ma bruciata c'è un po più piccola
non bruciamo l'angelo o possiamo rifare
questa cosa visto che potevo
facciamo un altro sei pronto schiva e
faremo un altro lupi capo del dis
anellare l'anello vieni this anellare
l'anello dalla molla esatto d'italia
nella secondo me ci mettiamo sei anni
però poi la forza serve poco ci ho
provato magari giallo vi svelo segreti
di guerrieri nei segreti di questo che
tutti provano a ospitarlo in realtà
basta girarli o come crea una figata 1
yard a via vai tu di là in giro da una
parte carattere e tutti pensano che
proprio a girare così invece tutta in
una votazione così all anello
esatto e lui riesce a metterlo al centro
un momento esatto che scriva arte hai
capito se grande hai capito il frigo
siccome
ok passiamo al prossimo oggetto ora
dovrai allenati sulla nuova skill quello
che dovrei imparare a fare
te lo faccio vedere contrario e questo è
mai
sei pronto allora il segreto che devi
imparare intanto c 6 c 6 prova aspetta
impara qualcuno solo etienne dole
inchieste questo guarda il gesto prima
passiamo al prossimo questo lo spiego
spiegano che tu lo farei a loro wow
ok velocizzeremo una spiegazione ma ti
aiuto se funzionale ed esagerato mai
allora ci prova come grazie c'è adesso
un indovinello per dimmi chi governa di
cuore noto dove tu dovrai fare
indovinando a loro va bene quindi questa
è una carta rossa no è una carta rossa
veroli esagerato lo stato uguale
guardane una fra di cucina un altro non
ti capo questo è difficile per avaria
pirlo è una scatola devi separare i loro
pezzi
mi senti qualcosa e accurato che è
difficile molto di mercato
avevo passato per genio prima devo
muovere cosa bene è una mossa sola che
va fatta al tavolo e una mossa solo una
sola mossa cavata aspetta questo
qualcosa che si muove sono dei chiodini
che entrano escono da qua e fanno sì che
si sblocchi c'è solo una mossa che fa sì
che si sblocchino ecco il concetto wow
figlio non lo saprei fare loro l'anno il
punto è che tu le hai fatte tutte hai
fatto la mossa che dovevi fare innescati
con le altre mosse
se tu vedi venire qua sono i chiodini
così è chiuso così tutti mi sono entrati
giri frascati a wow spiego che
incredibile e bellissimo andiamo con
questo che quella conosciamo questa
rossa e questa è morbida testa questa
volta questa che questa la stringe forte
to coast e niente
questa moneta per questa pallina dovrà
passare da qui a cui spetta più
difficile
torna indietro faccio veramente no vabbè
lega no aspetta aspetta aspetta what a
come non è così mi sono concentrato
tantissimo sulla mia mano non può essere
che pirla che sono ce n'erano di cose in
quel palco
insomma non sono venuto da boxe fa vj
rega adesso ho un regalo per te è questo
che cosa di carte che ho disegnato io e
in più ti insegnano a fare una cosa
insegna un altro
il bellissimo se le senti che sono
diversi dal normale se cioè scorso
motivo scorgono da dio
ok adesso imparerai fare questa cosa ok
questo è il tuo massimo sei serio no
aspetta dopo un bravo esagerato comandi
ma sta quindi ragazzi questo era il
video con jack l'unboxing ma il magico
ti senti adesso chiuderà jack con una
magia che farò una magia che ma già con
non so rendini bello non miracoli
qui i ragazzi sono rimini sia piaciuto
cosa si riferiva c'è un momento di
piacere anche dal canale giacche in
description funzione grazie per tutti i
trick famosissimi orellana e io faccio
cose così se tu vuoi chiuderei la
tiriamo si crea
[Applauso]
[Musica]